look at that beauty mercedes-benz
Stadium home of Super Bowl 50 3 is the
NFL's newest Stadium located in the
heart of downtown Atlanta the stadium
has a striking exterior that's been
compared to landmarks such as Sydney's
Opera House and the Disney Concert Hall
in Los Angeles but as the expression
goes it's not what's on the outside that
counts Dana Jacobson takes a look Dana I
like that saying Michelle good morning
again mercedes-benz does have all the
bells and whistles of a state-of-the-art
stadium but it also has art inside a
gallery's worth do you remember the
first time walking in and seeing the
piece other people around I did watch
people's faces and just see if they
actually paid attention to it world
renowned artist Radcliffe Bailey is
talking about conduits of contact
this piece spanning more than 72 feet
which he created not for a gallery or
museum show but to grace the concourse
inside Mercedes Benz Stadium I'm looking
at where I can go get a burger and then
this incredible piece of art above it
yeah I think about the sound to the roar
of crowds
Bailey's mixed-media artwork tells a
story about the gridiron when football
like all other parts of life was
segregated by race I'm thinking about
the trials and tribulations of the
people at the time period and
camaraderie I kind of soaked it in from
that angle
Bailey's work is one of 200 pieces of
art curated for the stadium so how do
you figure out where to put pieces of
art in a building the size we actually
worked with the architects in the early
stages of the design Penny McPhee is
president of the Arthur M Blanc Family
Foundation the philanthropic arm of its
namesake who owns mercedes-benz and the
NFL's Falcons we toured the stadium with
her while preparations were underway for
the Super Bowl people don't always think
art and football how do you
up with this idea that you're gonna have
works of art in football stadium Arthur
and his family are passionate about the
ability of art to touch everyone but I
think more importantly everything we did
in this stadium was meant to inspire awe
and Wonder an art is another way of
accomplishing that of surprising people
and giving them a WoW moment and
something they didn't expect merely
entering mercedes-benz you'll find those
wow moments from the 41 foot high 36
Plus ton metallic Falcon sculpture with
a wingspan of 70 feet which greets you
outside to inside we're an inspirational
quote welcomes you not from Vince
Lombardi but a revered ancient Jewish
leader if I am NOT for myself who will
be for me and if I am only for myself
then what am i and if not now when four
years
Arthur carried this quote from Hillel in
his wallet it says so much about who he
is as a person but it also says a lot
about teams and how we work together as
people the curation was led by SCAD the
Savannah College of Art and Design and
the fans voice can be found throughout
we actually asked them what kind of art
resonated with them they liked sculpture
they liked bold colors and they liked
motivational sayings which is why one
voice is such an important response to
the fans and this piece was made with
shoelaces shoelaces from people in the
area right from Falcons players Atlanta
United players and Georgia high school
football players all over the state in
other works the fan participation was
truly hands-on like this paper mache
piece created with some painting help
from kids at a local Boys and Girls Club
it was important to us to get kids
involved in the production of this art
and have feels some ownership when they
come to the stadium so
people are here for a football game
70,000 people are here for a soccer game
I would say a small percentage of those
folks routinely go to museums so for
them to have the experience apart in a
way that is meaningful to them that's
special that's part of what we hope to
do
and while McPhee hopes one day people
may even come to mercedes-benz Stadium
just to see the art for now it will
simply remain a part of a gameday
experience and for Atlanta native
Radcliffe Bailey that means being a part
of Super Bowl 53 forever I grew up in
the neighborhood close by so it feels
good as artists our work often lives
longer than we it's nice to be able to
fingerprint and as diverse as the
artists is as diverse as the mediums
they tried to get a different group of
artists 55 of them some from the area
15% african-american 25% female it's the
same way it's a diverse audience
watching a football game guys and it
really is an experience to tour the
place and see all of those beautiful
works of art it's a stunning building
Dana and I love what they've done I mean
it's just it's so great to bring art
into a community like that with people
who don't often see it and get them to
participate in the art it's just it's
it's great all around it gives you
something to look at something to
appreciate and you know you always learn
something love it